When we were working with equations for
Grant this last time, what we were really
doing was taking one expression, 87w+72n,
and subtracting from it another
expression, 3w+ And we worked with
parentheses in a kind of new way. So,
let's take a second, and talk a bit more
explicitly about how to add and subtract
polynomials. Let's start out by comparing
what the difference is between subtracting
polynomials and adding polynomials. So,
this first expression is what dealt with
in the last quiz. And we saw that because
there's a minus sign in front of a
quantity with parentheses around it, we
need to change the sign of the operator
that's in front of the 12n here. That's
inside the parentheses. So, here's what we
ended up with. We said that we needed to
subtract both the 3w and the 12n, so both
of them have minus signs in front of them
now. What if instead, though, we decided
to add them? So, we want to add this
entire quantity that's inside the
parentheses. So, here's a little quiz.
What terms would you put in this green box
right here to correctly complete this
expression over here? The key here is that
I want you to get rid of these parentheses
that are around the 3w+12n, and show me
how doing that changes the expression.
I've already put a plus sign right here
for you. So, that means that if you want
the first term in the box to be negative,
then I'd like you to put a negative sign
in front of it.